could we was on alright he posted this
on his instant Witter I believe saying
that he would give Tony Ferguson two
hundred thousand dollars of his own
money to fight him got dammed up what's
the plan um Liz inferred could be he's
making all the right moves the guy can't
get a fight no one wants to fight this
guy Tony from a business aspect it's
very smart he's saying listen there who
knows what's gonna happen this fight I
should be paid accordingly now Dana
White goes no no no you signed a
contract
we honor I I honor that contract you
need honor that contract the issue is
with that is the UFC doesn't honor that
contract cuz the UFC can cut you at any
given moment
meaning if you sign a six fight deal
they cut you one fight in to fight in so
just from a business aspect I totally
get what Tony Ferguson is trying to do
here and make sense I don't know if this
is the answer to his problems because
now you have could be putting up an
extra 200 K which is a shitload of money
more money that Tony's ever made for one
fight just that extra 200 but it let's
say Tony beats him yeah Tony's still on
that same contract it's good because
Dana might can say yeah you said six I
do it's tough to honor it whether you
beat could be or not khabib can give you
two academies money I don't give a [ __ ]
you're still under this contract so this
it's like it's like it's like dayquil
they kill doesn't cure anything if
you're sick in a mask it but then once
that day cruel wills lot wears off
you're still sick so this is just
covering up what would the problem is
it's a temporary solution for Tony
khabib just needs to fight he really
does man in my hearts out to him because
he deserves it the fight is Tony kabhi
that's the fight yeah
Conor's not fighting anytime soon khabib
Tony first thing at number one that is
the fight because you can't have Aldo vs
khabib even though that's what they want
to do and the third Dana said because
what happens to max Holloway at 45 is
their in term so then you hold up two
divisions and then let's say all they
get starched by kabhi which i think
would happen
let's eat could be just malls the [ __ ]
out of them like one of those [ __ ]
grizzly bears in Russia then [ __ ] with
ya
let's say he does that and then now max
hallway fights a degraded worn-out Jose
Ayala who just got his ass whupped with
who's gonna tune into that so again it's
a ripple effect if you make that fight
what happens amok max hall he's on nine
fight winning streak what happens to
Tony Ferguson who's on a nine when nine
fight winning streak what happens to
these guys who they've earned their keep
but we're not in that day and age of the
UFC this is the day and age of
entertainment what's gonna sell what's
gonna get the most eyeballs hints why
they Simon got signed a guy like CM Punk
I had a massage have you ever had a
massage where you can't prove it but you
feel like the woman is there's
something's going on
I'm a little too high up on that [ __ ]
how many well no it wasn't at you she
rubbed those well she's got she got in
she got in heavy she got she got the
forearms she got that she was using the
old forearms she was reaching under me
and for arming me wasn't just hands she
had she was up to she was up to me and
she had she was up to her elbows in me
you understand she was using her
forearms feeling me there's never been a
car down I'm both I'm both and then she
getting that elbow in that ass not
really the elbow she sure she's using
strong hands then she's just she's
taking her elbows and just massaging I
felt like she was like yes it's inside
that thought she got the inside of the
thigh cut working my dick goes high
working my apple bottom you dick goes
fellows let's do it well and of course I
can't be the creepy 50 year old because
that's why that's why we're compression
or real tight tight ease oh you got a
time now I gotta put them to the side
yeah like you know put them that's right
now now here's the problem obviously
here's the lip over here's the problem
I get flipped over and by the way I'm
naked I'm naked she tells me naked she
tell them to lose it all and just put on
this well this was her own she suggested
but very very pretty by the way and
French yeah yeah
do you flip over and was it like the
[ __ ] was it like a telescope it wasn't
because I I was like Marie I didn't want
to I don't want to be that guy right
here's my dick sorry okay I knew it it's
like it's natural sorry about my wife
and two kids and I'm here worth you know
oh it was a couple massage no no but I
was there but here's what I here's what
I'm getting at no problem here's what
I'm getting at she starts working the
old fingers okay nothing better and
she's she's she's giving me old soft
twist she's she's she's soft twisting
I'm not exaggerating
and then she's she's she's nipping she's
pulling that she's nipping it off
she's nipping my finger you know you if
you pretend you were gonna take the top
my finger off
she's nipping like hey is the first
digit does that pop off like a medicine
cap she's manipulating the joint there
though yeah the way you'd pop off like
it if you had a some sunscreen and you
had a little cut that look like that did
you feel good was [ __ ] felt great but
why are you did you stop doing this yes
yeah now you and I both know that most
of the time hand jobs suck you're gonna
[ __ ] me you better be a mighty Shawn
I know one woman in my life who was
great at hands out otherwise I'm like
way done I'm a sweet oh let's get her
hands are like dude [ __ ] Caston she
had magic hands wheel all the time magic
Hansel and toasted peace ya know now my
wife my wife listens to this podcast so
she's gonna hear this and I didn't tell
her at the time but she's giving me the
old and I'm going I think she's got to
be sending me a message here where she
wants to work work my shaft it's your
vacation I'm your boy well you've worked
so hard
hey that's the devil and I got Mazin I
wanna do a my friend here I know but I
got hands alone unless something yeah
how is it any different and I know man
do you listen listen how is it any
different if she takes those more my
lips are wet right if she hates those
moist calf leather skin oiled up hands
yeah and massage your foot for pleasure
yeah she massages you did what how's it
any different
I'm not pleasurable I'll sit any skin
skin I know I did different why is it
different
why is different just cuz she's a man
just cuz she's gonna make my banana cry
the guy attributed many of the problems
of the downfall of civilizations to
what's called hyper competence meaning
the big big systems that like even in
the
ion's right so when things started going
badly in Rome's bread and circuses so
like don't worry about what's going on
politically the fact that our leaders
are whacked out of their minds having
orgies just watch Christians being
thrown to the Lions and the whole sip
the whole that civilization right that
all nation-state that thought there but
they were gonna reign supreme forever
went under literally in a matter of like
a century for them was a short period of
time yeah and before them it was the
Mayans they started they started
attributing a lot of the resources
towards religious rituals and now it's
like I don't know I mean they got what
the guy was saying is that if we don't
get clear on what it is that we need to
attribute resources to we're not gonna
see the end coming it's just gonna be in
a bad seat and what every great nation
state is going like this
yeah every single one that's ever been
so the fact that you know I mean I don't
know but Brian suck I'm a global thing
ya know I have a lot of challenges I
mean this guy episode of the United
States and like the whole Trump thing
he's saying he's not gonna be he's he's
a symptom of the issue
yeah there's bigger issues Automation is
what steals jobs but you know what they
can't replace with robots you and I
buddy and good luck good luck being
funny how I really like being funny
check out the pit right remember the
pyramids ARBs all carbs to all carbs
certainly sent all guards terrible for
you yeah really that's [ __ ] food
pyramids
you'd be old beasts if you fall down
they were is what the problem is in a
capitalistic construct the things that
are gonna get promoted are always gonna
be related to something that can make it
that can make a profit that could turn a
profit why you have so look at the
oxycontin look at prescriptions look at
look at a prison industrial complex it's
always it unless it's if you don't think
for yourself if you don't have some
common sense you're gonna end up getting
[ __ ] you know common people don't have
the opportunity though right hey doll
you're working mom hey doll working
overtime Monday through Sunday at the
diner and you're smoking cigarettes I
don't [ __ ] know what am I gonna make
it Emma graph and asking it sir what the
[ __ ] that's statistically if you're
raising the project you'll probably end
up in the project for that reason you
don't you know it's like you keep making
the same stupid choices